mientras la guerra continúa en ucrania
europa paga su propio precio con
facturas de energía disparadas y los
líderes esforzándose por compensar los
crecientes costos a los 27 estados
miembros de la unión europea se les ha
pedido que reduzcan voluntariamente la
demanda de gas en un 15% en invierno
pero cada país está buscando sus propias
políticas de ahorro
francia se ha comprometido a un máximo
en el aumento del costo de la
electricidad del 4% y el precio del gas
habría subido en proporciones sin
precedentes si no hubiéramos
implementado ese tope de precios
eventualmente a principios del próximo
año en los próximos meses puede haber
aumentos que se pondrán sobre la mesa y
se discutirán
que en alemania los contribuyentes del
impuesto sobre la renta recibirán un
descuento único de 300 euros en el
precio de la energía y algunas familias
tendrán beneficios adicionales sin
embargo es probable que los hogares
terminen pagando 500 euros más al año
para ayudar a las empresas de servicios
públicos a cubrir el costo de la pérdida
del suministro de gas ruso
italia reservado desde enero más de
52.000 millones de euros para apoyar a
las familias de escasos recursos y
proteger a las empresas de la subida de
precios del gas países como bulgaria
grecia y rumanía han limitado los pagos
de los hogares a los productores de
energía y en países bajos polonia y
españa los locales comerciales notarán
un recorte en sus facturas en reino
unido- es probable que los residentes
vean otro aumento del 80 por ciento en
sus facturas anuales de energía aunque
el gobierno lanzó un paquete de apoyo de
37 mil millones de libras esterlinas se
le ha urgido a ser más
que la factura de todos tendrá un
descuento de 400 libras que en términos
del aumento adicional actual más o menos
equivale a la mitad pero sabemos que eso
no es suficiente
muy corto pese a estos esfuerzos los
analistas dicen que los hogares
británicos podrían pagar casi 500 libras
por mes solo de energía el próximo año
para muchos una suma más alta que el
mismo alquiler o la hipoteca